hello everyone how is it going happy
Thursday let me know everything sounds
good at home still as you can tell
that's not gonna stop our show from
happening every weekday at 2 p.m.
Pacific time and that's where we are
right now hope everyone is doing well um
its Bioshock Infinite's birthday so
obviously that means that we are gonna
be playing some Bioshock Infinite's
7 years it's been seven years since this
game came out which is actually pretty
crazy I didn't really play these games
when they had come out but I played them
a few years ago got the collection a few
years ago so why not play some BioShock
Infinite today so while we get underway
just one let you guys know that we
really appreciate you tuning in with us
every single day and it's always good to
see the familiar faces so shout outs to
Brandon for always being here hello
victor matt sophie real horror story is
dark hunter ace the star game rick DJ
everybody what's up how's it goin thank
you so much for being here
let's play some freaking BioShock
Infinite shall we i redownload the
collection onto this console so I'm
gonna have to adjust some things alright
let's do it
I'm excited it's been a really long time
since I played this actually a couple
years Bioshock is your childhood says
Daniel oh snap I was in level of
difficulty let's keep it show let's keep
it chill it's medium levels
can you guys hear the game okay sound
good hello Sasha
how's it goin and happy a big day Booker
are you afraid of God no I'm afraid of
you the mind of the subject will
desperately struggle to create memories
where none exists
are you going to just sit there as
compared to one standing not standing
rowing rowing planned on it
so you expect me don't be scare if I had
to be in a situation like do expect you
to do in a tiny little boat in the
middle of the sea use your idea and I
made it very clear that I don't believe
you know imagine that's wonderful
exercise we want the entire thoughts
move this one goes into experiment
knowing one one does not undertake an
experiment and add a failed story etc
him definitely not but crits in the cops
coming to damn Anita please well it's
it's birthday you might have loved
I'll really say this is a horror game
turn on subtitles I could be playing too
much Animal Crossing pressing the wrong
button I'm going somebody meeting me
here I'd certainly hope so
it does seem like a dreadful place to be
stranded
what's up like we can be alien welcome
back von Miller this is a BioShock
Infinite it's been seven years to the
day of this game are revisiting it it's
been a really long time excuse me that's
a girl I guess they're expecting me oh
man it's like every step I take I'm like
oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
it's hard to believe that this games
already seven years old
does anyone here hello
[Music]
the Trinity says it feels like it was
released two years ago yeah seriously oh
[Music]
man I don't like the headphones on
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
bloody handprint hmm
he knows nuts I don't see the Tor game
but this definitely it scared me I was
like holy crap this guy done got chopped
up there's all these creepy creaking
sounds I have like farming mentality
right now because of animal crossing I'm
like yes
pick up everything
what's up mark saying hi from England
how's it going
did it not apply the subtitle
[Music]
whatup Akash welcome back how's it goin
[Music]
ya guys tomorrow community Friday with
Ben and John Luke they're gonna be
playing Animal Crossing so get the cells
are ready
[Music]
[Music]
alright looks like they expect me
hey Trish your friend
bogum buh-bye this will be a live stream
tomorrow it'll just be enjoy man what if
I made this like come on Aviles story
beers brides and like an amusement park
what the wild but happening anyways
everybody rushes world where they had
all the avatar oh my god
[Music]
because we're being so scary it's
actually just really beautiful
[Music]
good luck
father Comstock Joe says I remember
playing some Bioshock thinking how weird
it was not to aim with a left trigger I
why would he send to us I actually
really liked this part the way the light
shines through I feel the same way about
that only because I'm I'm just so
spoiled now look like a biessing with
the left sugar a ton of other games
because I noticed and even like doom
eternal I use the sticky grenades so
much because it just feels more natural
to you aim with the left trigger and it
shoot so yeah I definitely feel you
there no construction no there's still
construction but luckily for me they're
not using the jackhammer today they were
just using the saw which when the doors
closed you can't really hear which is
good but yeah yesterday I have this
crazy construction going on right across
the street from my house and they needed
the jackhammer
they've been taking the build whatever
there but I said yes sir getting ready
to build an apartment building or
something but it it's crazy
nice laughing how epic all of these
looks
the whole atmosphere subtitles brother
the only way to Colombia is through
birth in the Sweetwater's it is real
creepy when they're all looking at you
like that in the in the
[Music]
[Music]
that's one way to be baptized we've made
it to learn the difference between
baptizing a man and drowning her I need
to find a landmark and figure out what
the hell I am
I'll profit all right we're out just cuz
the city flies don't mean it ain't got
its fair share of fools all right
[Music]
not gonna lie this stage the way of
floats and moves definitely and gets my
head all facing
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah following the life
[Music]
No give me a socks all wet like that now
I'm good
[Music]
there's just so much to look out
everything's floating come on be a
raffle and fair
would you care for a boutonniere we're
raising money for the girls patriotic
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I mean
I don't know I would not have wanted to
bend my knife like that
he is now
it's not those Harmon
[Music]
have I played an update of call of duty
mobile nah I have not actually play call
of duty mobile in a while I played it a
lot when it first came out though it was
pretty fun I heard people were trying to
use their controllers on their phones
I'm too late mr. Duane telegram for you
sir
well why thank you to wit stop do not
alert Comstock to your present stop
whatever you do do not take number 77
hello my good day to you sir
hello hello good day I am an average
member of your community the whole
office
you know just like all of San Francisco
right now is on lockdown but we're still
trying to bring you guys streams and
content everybody else these guys are
yelling I've heard knocks
leave a on some lockdown right now in
currency and then feel free to join us
we are playing every single day at 2:00
p.m. sethe time that's got content going
up I'm playing on ps4 right now I got in
the collection a couple years ago so I
was pretty excited to like have a reason
to download it and play it
[Music]
[Music]
with a beloved spouse I don't know if I
would consider this word but there are
definitely some crazy parts for sure I
am just walking
oh yes and that don't mean me yeah let's
do it so we can how convenient that you
is standing right next so am i right
yeah
it always makes me laugh with game logic
it's like oh yeah this weird lecture or
biome that I have no idea what it is
sure I'll join
I totally bought my tickets hotels come
on let me through
hey tails tails told you chin up there's
always next time
those guys like how many freakin points
for it sir so funny
[Music]
what they put in the updates on for Call
of Duty mobile well woof oh look I have
not played the DLC so you're right
actually deputy assistant out yeah the
whole division
[Music]
everyone's like oh my god you can see
that that was kind of was baby mice
it was welding down I wish I had some
gloves right now man
I honestly don't even remember how the
combat feels so many different like
shooter games lately
my little little clumsy at first bite
ooh that collection was free on PSN not
long ago I did not know that I bought
this a few years ago this is a good
collection me sorry you say silly
there's never a charge for the raffle
you've been sleeping under a rock 707
why would you pick it up with that hand
it's just flashing it have a hole
everything
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right then no winner
[Applause]
[Music]
that's mhm
are you taking your coffee please
Oh looks like we've got a shy one would
you get that Brad don't you know that
makes you the backstab and
snake-in-the-grass fault Shepard
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
search your body
I'm alone so yeah those thing about this
game the running and looking around on
the way
[Music]
oh yeah
my friend
Matt presenting machine always
they're firing up something on me
whoo okay I need to be careful with how
long
and you can see that big man
okay
[Music]
it's getting hot what's going on
[Music]
like nice art and then like korrina's
without it ever really feeling too crazy
like all your books and the sciences
mama says it's not a fit occupation for
a lady but I think she's jealous of our
cleverness is it true that only you were
allowed to visit the girl in the tower
if the land is lonely too I should like
to meet her I'd have much in common
mr. guy Thank You robot
[Applause]
alright well we made it it's fine she
make a video on Call of Duty
we've played call of duty on stream
before like we played when war zone came
out and when modern warfare drops I'm
always down to do some color duty stuff
for sure
yeah they're running well yeah I
remember
I remember watching some people doing
speedruns or something like that
and for this game and they were saying
something about how one of these gives
you like the power of that's between a
lot basically like makes it much easier
for you to get through everything I
don't remember what it was or anything
but they were just doing an example run
and they ended up getting that item and
they were like oh I'm actually so
obsessed but this isn't a full run
because I wanted all of it
[Music]
yeah yeah if there's an update for
mobile oh actually I can't stream on
mobile from home I know in the office
I'm able to you but I don't have all the
gear for that I was gonna say maybe you
should stream this comedy mobile update
[Music]
oh wait I just can i take all of you was
it only a Pheo or two or something like
that
I don't know why I thought I could only
take oh there's another table over here
[Music]
[Music]
why did I think I can only take one
surprise me we're out um I don't think
we've done a livestream of Call of Duty
mobile but we'd Emily have some footage
up
wait what did I miss
okay I was like then I grab that oh did
not see these either ah my buttons are
all backwards right now
[Music]
the streets I know
[Music]
or Gandhism with this skyhook
oh damn hook must be magnetized
[Music]
whoa whoa Maggie Lizer
it was bounded jumped over pass area
with a hidden chest oh that is probably
gonna happen a lot I probably just ready
to go through a lot of hit and stuff
like this run them anytime and I want to
be able to get as far as I can
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Paul says I'm still happy to come in to
switch heck yeah
hey maybe we find another reason to play
this game let's see
Oh
this game definitely has it's scary
moments or its creepy moment yeah like
all of this
everybody must go steal then all the
food off of that table sorry guys I'm
not running much some reason the running
the very tasty game yes always some
always miss just sensible since the DLC
for this is underrated
I definitely check it out I have not
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my god there's a search corpse it's not
like just as loot it's like they only
gonna know you're rummaging through
someone's dead body all right well that
guy's straight up bounce right Brandon
it's true I feel the same way so many
games on the backlog right now and then
so many good ones that come back around
for like birthdays and stuff like this
so some hunting rifles I miss it
trouble began almost instantly
Isaiah makes a good point he says it's a
really great trilogy he makes me sad
that we haven't seen a new series like
this also looking forward to a sequel or
reboot but worried they won't live up to
the originals that's always the thing
right you want more of a series that you
love but there's always a worrying that
it won't live up to expectations or this
or that so the cool thing is they're at
least making like ports and DLCs for a
lot of games now so that's always good
this one's also it's a lot different
from the other one
[Music]
sorry dude
[Music]
[Music]
what's this I don't know but we're gonna
use this doesn't matter what it is
you're still gonna drink it game logic
yes and we're gonna wreak havoc on every
this probability probably one of my oh
man I shouldn't have skipped the
tutorial the tutorials are always super
cute yeah I love the crows actually
[Music]
[Music]
it's good every time had a hot dog in a
fight I like the crow ability a lot
whoo Bioshock 4 remember is a August I
feel like I heard so many rumors for
games all the time I try not to get my
hopes up video shoot
come to the station here
I've been taking up all this silver and
I prefer the B's over the road
ahö limits huh
we don't know the meaning of the words I
[Music]
remember this part
maybe I should have played this one
harder to play I feel like ever since I
started ever since I started doing the
carnival on nightmare mode I feel like I
can take on the world now just super fun
super challenging and like stressful but
in a good way
really it's like there was something in
the air like there was something in here
I don't remember
I could be buggin ya
oh yes oh man if I thought I was getting
motion sickness running
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
better already
yeah do you know
oh snap sure you supplying bleeding-edge
duh yeah oh man I was going to play
yesterday but construction I'm still
gonna try it download it though
when they found me but
oh here we go
[Music]
[Music]
we're days already
[Music]
[Music]
skyline above get some elevation
Oh every I'll get back up here
I definitely hear them
RIT says I miss Big Daddy I know it's
it's really interesting how different my
first one is
day after I get back up here he'll do
he said get some elevation
oh there it is
[Music]
these are low
maybe able to hop I don't even like
another
music
[Music]
[Music]
and now to repay it dances don't know me
well he knows your name
prophecy is my business mr. to ask blood
is yours do you know why these men died
because I've seen
[Applause]
[Music]
controls to take this thing to monument
i'll
[Music]
I'm just so I don't have to amen amen
like should I have to
oops
there we go
easy
right we made it to monument tower
trying to rush this down so we can so we
can see the girl know where they got her
locked up in this place
[Music]
[Music]
oh dang
quarantine see all of us we're all under
quarantine right now
so creepy
[Music]
facility is unsafe
[Music]
[Music]
what games came out in 2013 this the
Last of Us Saints here for what are you
missing
oh man that's like that's a heavy
question I feel like there are so many
games I forget about Ethan's games like
they came out within the last two years
or something like that
GTA 5 I remember trying to escape from
there and always running the wrong way
like a very elaborate
very elaborate like teach I guess
[Music]
really totally creeping on Anna
[Music]
he's like what makes her so special and
then imagine seeing something like this
[Music]
although pretty cool I was had that
power
[Music]
it's got nothing to do with the job at
hand
this job's getting worse every time
stuff gets worse every time I don't even
think you've ever experienced it out
like this that's for sure he's still
oddly calm about the whole situation he
just saw her rip a hole into like space
out of the air she just manifested a
whole another part of Earth so yeah he's
like oh man so crazy but I would have
been losing it she does remind me of
Belle actually
I can do this
right it's like she looks like Bella and
this time like a single who are you my
name is do it I'm a friend
she's like you you'll know what I can do
[Music]
I hear there's no way out trust me I
stop it you're you're too impatient
that's enough what about this
like yeah you have the key
[Music]
[Music]
oh wait am I supposed to open it again
yeah I forgot it had things like that
really she runs in
about that
just one question
[Music]
[Music]
even though why
what am I your the girls is getting out
of this tower
[Music]
out of the way let me try
Larry says the full regime
and definitely on my throat's that refer
excuse me
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
No
terrifying
[Music]
[Music]
it's so creative
what's so so epic yes right making good
time the same Marvel I wish I wished
Yugi six wishes some marble maybe one
day online was better I've always wanted
to you know get some marble heads on the
streets you know how it'd be no it's me
you all right back in the land of the
living yeah let me we find you're almost
round he needs I said
[Music]
so what about you guys in the chat are
you um I'm gonna be playing this again
to celebrate the summer long story sir
Scott what up how's it goin
I like this little town
I mean maybe not all the craziness going
on but around here in the house the
bright side
screaming hang out with you guys every
day
[Music]
bujjamma sizes on bioshock unite this is
what I need right now some work out get
active gonna be playing animal crossing
more nice noise oh sorry
[Music]
there's says I mean it's the best one
for ten years
I like the first one
[Music]
or I'm really missing a surgeon
[Music]
no more things right all I want is fair
paid for an honest day's work
I remember getting lost on this present
first thank you
[Music]
or your door on the side
[Music]
or was she dancing a huge dancing
hey miss
this is definitely single dance
[Music]
you're right and he said it's so cool
peaches I know DOS oh wait oh so shadow
represent if you listen to the music if
girls just want to have fun when I was
on the dock I was like I don't hear it
but it's the music that's playing out
here on the beach and it totally is that
is so cool
thank you for the fun fact they also
searched passing well furry really cool
mr. - what's my favorite game that's
tough
I have a lotta games are really really
really loved you have a man oh no I
guess I would say halo 2 is my favorite
yeah we're going all into the water did
you no favors I'll keep an eye out for
mr. DeWitt here or the cage or perhaps
the bird nothing beats the cage he's
doing you actually forgot if these
little things make a big difference
these they're men I always this one this
the bird is beautiful I always pick the
birds I'm like the one on the right are
you sure I'm sure
I love it surprising Jason focus games
all the cool everybody pretty much do
this again they're just now noticing
that happening cuz we've been running
around for quite a bit and that thing
fell apart
oh wow
come on let's get out of here before ma
they're onto us
we're taking them up Alohomora surprise
[Music]
it's probably a good I don't even know
how much money I owe 923 I'm rich my
level of that oh I mean
hey hey mister we'd like to help you do
I know I've gotten away no Daisy always
said somebody like you Johnny's been
playing Splinter saw lately noise pick
nice pick alright thanks guys take care
sir would you no no time no time at all
excuse me Annabel it's me Esther oh no
I'm not Annabel are you sure my name is
Elizabeth do I know you
Elizabeth isn't that a lovely name I was
last customer at all marks closing
everyone I'm walk-in here two tickets
for passage to the first lady airship I
played this game to completion alike a
thousand times in a bit of a rush pal I
[Music]
got it I'll ring you back once that
matters in hand I don't like this yes
send in the bird we're ready to execute
excuse me can I get some help here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah you need help with that lever don't
hear I see you later Brandon yes
definitely tune in tomorrow we can all
hang out happy island together
choo-choo crazy people thanks for tuning
in as all animals store you see what did
you think was gonna happen
do you understand the expense people
went through to keep you locked up in
that time
you think people like that are just
gonna let you walk away you are an
investment and you will not be safe
until you are far yes crippled and
dimension from possibly winning closer
but that's the last time anyone does the
drop on me
yeah I should have shot him is your hand
what happened back there it's not the
last I don't know
[Music]
all righty got a few minutes
[Music]
yep try there long this
hate heading to the soldiers field how
far can we get invited
[Music]
you know look at dolls like this low-key
creeped me out and if anybody has ever
been to Disney World they had that it's
a small world right and I went on it and
it was cute but also very confusing but
that's what you thought this reminded me
you shut up tight now how are we gonna
get to the ocean let me see if I can get
that gate open by hand yeah I'm just
gonna use my my raw muscles just kidding
my hands hurt
[Music]
firstly it's heading to the dock
call me
[Music]
[Music]
of course it does
better in some games than others but
look how powerful their game with hero
it'll do
[Music]
here
[Music]
little comb you guys just flatten only
all did it looks like there won't be a
line to get in my bloody hand he got the
jump on me something wrong the classic
oh nothing I can't fix we just gotta do
everything don't we
Osby I just fill it down Elizabeth Jesus
you here time to fix fuse box o
meanwhile time in my tower what is a
terror it's like a a window I window to
another world most of the time they're
done really quite right in a different
colored towel or tea instead of coffee
but sometimes sometimes I see something
amazing
I don't suppose you've got a bishop in
there think so but there is there is
something I love that it pops out right
behind that poster of the bird I don't
really understand what I just saw back
there like a shortcut to getting us
killed
but I could help I can handle whatever
comes along trust me
have it your way I suppose oh right you
guys that is actually gonna wrap it up
for today's stream but thank you guys so
so much for tuning in and hanging out it
always means a lot to us you know it's
crazy time out there and if we can make
that any better by just hanging out
live-streaming with you guys making
great content for you guys and that's
what we want to do and the fact that you
guys like it too is really what makes it
all worth it so thank you guys so much
for tuning in and celebrating bioshock
infinite seventh birthday by playing
through it with me and we will be live
tomorrow with community Fridays are
gonna be playing Animal Crossing so get
everything ready so you can come visit
our Island and we can all have a little
party it's gonna be really fun so make
sure you tune in for that
John lickin Ben we'll be holding it down
and I'm gonna be playing - let's guys
all join in so hope to see you guys
there I think guys so much for hanging
out and watching and we'll see you guys
next time peace out take care and stay
safe
you